[Music]
all right let's go to tanner in
vancouver what's up tanner how are we
doing
hi how are you i'm great how about you
nope not cheaper sorry not too bad i
just uh i have a
uh i guess it's a marriage column um
me and my wife are fine and we're
stronger than ever but
um my my rights last night um
she has an issue um being around my my
mother um alone
she my mom has went and turned around
and uh
i've never witnessed it but my mom has
went and talked to her
talk down to her um and i'm just i'm
trying to know
i'm trying to be faithful to my wife and
not not people but loyal to my wife
um but i just i don't know where to go
with this
so we were just talking about that with
this blinds.com call
um when you say talk down to what what
did your wife tell you
how about that uh her name is katarina
okay what did katherine she came to you
last night and said and what'd she say
um well she didn't say anything i was
talking to her
because we're planning a trip out to
them um
i i live on in vancouver and my
in-law or my my family lives out in
ontario
and i i left
ontario because i needed to make a
drastic move because my
my family and her have never gotten
along and we have a
10 year old in the mix of it so i'm
trying to do what's right by my
my wife and and i just i've never heard
her
heard my mother say anything so i don't
and i'm not saying that my wife is
overreacting because
is your wife's not doing this stanner is
your wife lying to you
i don't i don't think so i i honestly
like she has no reason to lie
i don't care about any of that stuff is
your wife lying to you okay
no okay then i want you to sit down and
hear your wife let her be open to you
and then at some point you have a
responsibility to go to your mom
and say this stops now yeah because i
pick her over you and if my if your
mom's gonna act like a child and your
mom's gonna run your wife down
which is which by proxy is gonna run
down your 10 year old in the mix here
then your mom is self-selecting out of
your relationship
and i know that's a hard conversation
and it's an uncomfortable conversation
and it's a
conversation but this is one of those
hard-line moments right
it is and tanner i can even hear it in
your voice though he wants he wants to
do the right thing for his wife that's
right you know
like this wasn't like my wife you know
sometimes it's pinned the other way
where the wife's the bad one you know
situ in the situation
but you you know yeah you're in a
marriage and you're number one as your
wife
and and i feel that from you and i think
sitting down and having that boundary
conversation
it'll either clear it up and it'll stop
it or it's gonna
cause more friction between you guys
well i think it clears up either way
right yeah yeah yeah tanner it's
important you don't go to war with your
mom and don't be disrespectful and don't
be ugly and don't
call and be like you should that's not
how you do that you go visit your mom
right yes and you have this conversation
in person and say hey i love
my wife and she's who i chose and here's
the deal too
i think some women can be passive some
women maybe alter
extend i don't know we could be passive
aggressive at times so your mom
well she probably knows what she's doing
she may not even know the weights
that a flippant comment can make that
was very hurtful do you know what i mean
so to
i don't know but i know they had a rocky
relationship you said they've never
really liked her so there's probably
gonna be a lot of stuff there to unpack
but
and this is a conversation that you have
respectfully and with dignity yeah
but this is a moment when you step up
for your family and for your
wife and your kid and you say i'll go
talk to my mom
that's right